he is the most unpopular U.S president
of modern times but Joe Biden's
Democrats have achieved a historically
good set of results it was a good day I
think for democracy
and I think it was a good day for
America he lost few receipts and House
Representatives than any Democratic
President's first midterm election the
last 40 years
and we had the best midterm for
Governors since 1986. he is savoring
some rare good news hey Buddy Joe Biden
congratulations man congratulations
especially with doubts over whether a
man who turns 80 in 10 days time will
run for re-election
hey gov congratulations my intention is
that I've run again but I'm a great
respecter of fate and uh this is
ultimately a family decision my guess is
to be early next year we make that
judgment another possible candidate for
the 2024 race is holed up at his
Mar-A-Lago Resort after many of Donald
Trump's candidates failed to make waves
there are reports he is angry and
wounded especially after the success of
his Republican rival Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis
counting continues in Nevada and Arizona
for two Senate seats which could decide
who has control of the Upper House in
Phoenix Arizona far from Washington
views on the next occupant the White
House are mixed
I don't know
I really hope Trump doesn't run I'd like
to see him get indicted but
as for Biden I don't know kind of
indecisive I'm not saying I'm a trump
supporter
like you're not gonna see me with a mega
hat on
but I think he's better than Joe Biden
Joe Biden is much older but who should
be we were watching I do ride to
shannonis without a doubt right to
Santa's sat himself up last night whilst
it could be a few more days before we
have the final results here Nationwide
there are clear and consequential Trends
and the balance of power particularly in
the Republican Party seems to be
shifting
as the electability of one Contender and
the candidacy of another are being
questioned it is very possible the Old
Guard will soon be replaced with new
faces